if you are in my comments or
defending me anywhere telling
people that i did nothing wrong
please stop
that's not our place
to tell people what they can and can't
be
offended about you know that's that's
wrong
um and that's part of the problem rachel
curcanell
is opening up about the racism
controversy surrounding both
her and the bachelor franchise please
stop
saying that i did nothing wrong that's
not true
you know if you really want to support
me then and encourage me to do better
and encourage those around you to do
better and
to accept change and and allow others to
learn
and grow because we need to work
together
on this if if anything is going to
change
the bachelor contestant took to
instagram on thursday where she shared
that video message explaining how she's
taking responsibility for her past
racist actions you know over the last
few weeks
um since i've put my statement on i've
gotten a lot of messages
um i've gotten a lot of people asking me
well what have you done to change since
then
but then there's also people messaging
me saying you know
you've done nothing wrong don't listen
to people
and i'm i'm just i'm tired
of getting all of this and
not saying anything and um
i think that the first big step in
all of this is white people
stepping up and and taking
accountability
and you know things things will never
change
if we don't all work together
and you know working towards this
this racial progress and this unity that
that we want
the 24 year old says that she debated
whether to post
links and information for others who
wish to educate themselves on racial
injustice in america
but she was worried how it would look i
don't want
people thinking that you know it's it's
performative or it's it's not
something that i don't truly stand by
and i get it i i hear you
um there are things out there
that completely validate your
your opinions and and your anger towards
me
um but i've just i've come to realize
that that's sitting aside and
and hiding in the corner and
you know avoid being called performative
that doesn't help anyone the reality
star also shot down fans who are
defending her past
actions and asked them to stop weighing
in if you are
in my comments or defending me
anywhere telling people
that i did nothing wrong
that there's nothing to be hurt about
there's nothing to be angry about or
offended about
please stop controversy first erupted
earlier this month when long-time
bachelor host chris harrison
gave an interview with former
bachelorette rachel lindsay
defending kirkunel's past racist
behavior which included attending a
plantation party when she was in college
in 2018.
the picture was reported from 2018
at an old south antebellum party so i
think
you know well rachel
is it a good look in 2018 or is it not a
good look in 2021
because there's a big deal he later
issued an
apology announcing he's taking time off
from the show
and will not be hosting the after the
final rose special with current bachelor
matt james
and the winning contestant kerkinell
issued her own apology at the time
saying she hopes to earn forgiveness
through her future actions
this entire movement and where we are in
this country
it's it's just so much bigger than this
and i want and
a need to use my my privilege and
my platform that i so do not deserve um
just to shine a light on these issues
and try and do
what i can to
you know take a step in the right
direction